den einen kam es viel zu spät den
anderen ist es nach wie vor nicht
geheuer das Jahr zur Lieferung von
Leopard 2 Panzern durch Bundeskanzler
Scholz lange brauchte Olaf Scholz für
diese Entscheidung richtig so sagen die
ein die anderen waren in des vor dem
möglichen Folgen nämlich dass die
Entscheidung den Westen zu Kriegspartei
machen könnte und kaum ist die
kampferpanzerdebatte beendet geht es um
den nächsten wochentyp Kampfflugzeuge
wohin also führt uns die
panzerentscheidung von Olaf Scholz darf
oder muss es auch im Ziel ein
militärischen Sieg Russlands zu
verhindern rote Linien für das Handeln
des Westens geben darüber wollen wir
heute reden und ich begrüße Sie sehr
herzlich bei Unter den Linden
[Musik]
und ich begrüße Sie herzlich bei uns
Jürgen hart den außenpolitischen
Sprecher der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion herzlich
willkommen und ich begrüße Sie herzlich
Michael Müller
Mitglied des Auswärtigen Ausschusses von
der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion ebenfalls
herzlich Willkommen an Sie Herr Müller
Kanzler Scholz hat die Lieferung von
Leopard 2 Panzern an die Ukraine über
deutsche von Deutschland freigegeben
aber auch für andere Länder freigegeben
sind sie erleichtert dass die
Entscheidung jetzt so gefallen ist das
nachvollziehbar jetzt wenn man sich den
Kriegsverlauf anguckt und die Debatten
die es ja intern offensichtlich auch
zwischen den Verbündeten gegeben hat in
den letzten Wochen das ist eine
nachvollziehbare Entscheidung die der
Ukraine mit Sicherheit auch eine
erhebliche Hilfe jetzt ist wenn die
Panzer geliefert werden aber wichtig war
natürlich und insofern muss man auch
akzeptieren dass das ein bisschen dauert
dass es wirklich eine Verständigung gibt
und nachdem nun USA und Deutschland
gesagt haben wir wollen diesen Weg gehen
waren ja schnell dann auch Spanien kanad
Niederlande andere bereit also insofern
ja jetzt eine Entscheidung die getroffen
werden musste so oder so zu diesem
Zeitpunkt aber mit diesem Weg den Scholz
jetzt auch frei gemacht hat zusammen mit
beiden ist das doch denke ich eine große
Unterstützung es hat massiven Druck
gegeben von Seiten des Auslands aber
auch von Seiten der Unionsfraktion
auch von Seiten der Medien sagt der eine
oder andere Viren Sie diesen Druck
empfunden ja natürlich ist das so wir
haben das ja alle gespürt in den letzten
Wochen natürlich eine große
Erwartungshaltung ja erstmal auch von
der Ukraine ja ausgedrückt und
nachvollziehbar die Menschen dort
kämpfen um ihr Land sie kämpfen ums
Überleben und wollen die bestmögliche
Unterstützung und das ist natürlich
schon auch eine erheblicher Druck auch
wenn man die Bilder sieht die er so
bedrückend sind aus der Ukraine aber
natürlich haben viele auch gesagt wir
wollen möglichst schnell möglichst alles
liefern ich bin sehr froh und ich glaube
wie viele andere auch das ist aber nach
wie vor gar nicht in Frage steht dass
wir helfen dass eine
Selbstverständlichkeit und trotzdem wir
immer diesen Abwägungsprozess haben wann
machen wir was mit wem wie können wir
gut unterstützen ohne dass diese
Situation noch weiter eskaliert oder
sogar die NATO Kriegspartei wird das
müssen wir vermeiden und insofern finde
ich es richtig trotz dieser angespannten
Lage sich auch die Zeit zu nehmen um
mögliche Konsequenzen intensiv zu
beraten das ist hier keine Spielerei es
geht um ein Krieg vor unserer Haustür
und da muss es erlaubt sein sich auch
diese Zeit zu nehmen
aber auch sie selbst haben sich sehr
früh und auch vehement durchaus für die
Lieferung von Leopard 2 Panzern
ausgesprochen fühlen sich jetzt
bestätigt
wir fühlen uns bestätigt ich glaube man
könnte jetzt noch viel zu dem zu der
generisser sagen also wenn der
französische Staatspräsident noch
Sonntag vor Ort Tagen das war ja 36
Stunden vor der Entscheidung 24 Stunden
vor der Entscheidung des Bundeskanzlers
wir werden nicht nur an dem gemessen was
wir machen sondern auch an dem was wir
nicht machen habe ich das eine klare
Adresse das französische
Staatspräsidenten an den deutschen
Bundeskanzler gesehen sich jetzt zu
bewegen ähm es ist gut dass es jetzt
geschehen ist ich sage nur es wäre
wahrscheinlich auch aus Sicht von Scholz
die bessere Idee gewesen vielleicht im
Sommer zu sagen wir modernisieren Panzer
wir bilden ukrainische Streitkräfte aus
und dann entscheiden wir
situationsabhängig ob wir sie liefern
oder nicht das wäre vielleicht ein
Mittelweg gewesen ein goldener weg
gewesen der auch als klare Botschaft an
Moskau da gestanden hätte dass man
gesagt hätte wir bereiten uns vor wir
haben die Entscheidung noch nicht
getroffen du Putin hast es in der Hand
mit der Art und Weise wie du jetzt
weiter militärisch gegen die Ukraine
vorgehst ob wir das für notwendige 8
oder nicht denn meine große Sorge ist
dass wenn wir einmal die Geschichte
dieses Überfalls Russlands auf die
Ukraine schreiben dass wir
möglicherweise sagen die letzten drei
Monate hat Putin besser genutzt als der
Westen Schrägstrich die Ukraine weil
nämlich Putty doch tatsächlich über
100.000 von seinen Rekruten jetzt
einigermaßen vernünftig ausgebildet hat
der hat Material aus verschiedenen
Militärbezirken zusammengezogen hat die
große das große Manöver mit mit
Weißrussland mit Belarus gemacht er ist
besser vorbereitet und eine dritte
Offensive droht und wenn das tatsächlich
uns an einen Punkt bringt das hier dass
die Ukraine in ihrer existenzgefährdet
ist dann kriegen wir noch ganz andere
Diskussion das hätten wir vielleicht
vermeiden können wenn wir bereits im
Herbst oder jetzt im Winter die Panzer
in die Ukraine Handy liefern können
Müller auf hier geht es ja um Krieg ist
es nicht auch richtig dass da lange
abgewogen wird es lange überlegt wird
was die richtigen Schritte sind es geht
ja nicht darum dass wir irgendwie einen
Krieg vom Zaun brechen sondern die Frage
wie reagieren wir auf diese kriegerische
Aktion und wir haben es acht Jahre lang
diplomatisch versucht ja die
Bundeskanzlerin der französische
Staatspräsident normandie-format mindest
eins mit zwei diese ganzen Gespräche
haben zu nichts geführt im Gegenteil
russland hat sich vorbereitet auf den
Überfall der Ukraine und hat die dann ab
24 Februar letzten Jahres auch vollzogen
und wir haben ein vitales Interesse
daran dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg
gewinnt ich sage wenn es nicht gelingt
der Ukraine nicht gelingt Putin zu
stoppen dann werden wir früher oder
später mit der Frage Moldau Georgien
vielleicht auch mit der Frage bald
gekommen also Korridor nach kalinika
getroffen werden
nicht Russland darf nicht gewinnen
sondern die Ukraine muss gewinnen
ich glaube dass wir
Putin anhand Punkt bringen müssen wo er
für sich selbst feststellt dass die
Fortführung des Kampfes für ihn
gefährlicher ist als in tatsächliche
ernsthafte Verhandlungen einzutreten an
dem Punkt sind wir noch lange nicht und
dieser Punkt hängt entscheidend davon ab
wie schwierig die Ukraine diese
militär-operation wie er sagt diesen
Krieg gegen die Ukraine macht und
deswegen glaube ich das muss als
oberstes Ziel dort stehen die Ukraine
muss diesen Krieg gewinnen wir müssen
Putin in eine Verhandlungsposition
zwingen und dann haben wir eine
Möglichkeit einen Frieden einen
dauerhaften nachhaltigen Frieden
hinzubekommen haben wir noch mal zu dem
was viele die Zögerlichkeit des Kanzlers
oder von Stolz singen dass er inzwischen
Rede
bezeichnet haben viele sagen auch
dadurch ist durchaus Schaden auch bei
den Bündnispartnern entstanden sehen Sie
das auch so nein das glaube ich nicht
weil ja alle anderen auch in diesem
Abwägungsprozess sind und es ist richtig
macron äußert sich genauso wie die
Staatschefs aber ich empfinde das
mitunter auch als Selbstkritik denn
Deutschland macht viel mehr als
Frankreich ich glaube Frankreich war
jetzt in der Situation wo sie auch
handeln mussten aufgrund der Debatte die
es auch in Frankreich gibt also insofern
glaube ich akzeptiert jeder der
Bündnispartner dass das keine einfachen
Entscheidungen sind dass man die eigene
Bevölkerung mitnehmen muss auf diesen
Weg dass man diese Abstimmungsprozesse
zwischen den internationalen Partnern
braucht das viel von den Amerikanern
abhängt die sich relativ wenig
vorschreiben lassen um es mal vorsichtig
zu sagen sondern sehr selbst tun
sehr selbstbewusst entscheiden was sie
für richtig und falsch halten und
insofern das geht nicht von heute auf
morgen das weiß man hinter den Kulissen
finden alle Gespräche statt unter finde
ich müssen wir auch so schwer es
mitunter auch für uns
Bundestagsabgeordnete ist weil wir
natürlich auch erwarten dass die
Regierung uns ihr Handeln erklärt und
auch detailliert informiert aber selbst
wir müssen akzeptieren dass es Gespräche
gibt die man nicht in die Öffentlichkeit
beitragen kann in so einer
Krisensituation und insofern ist da nach
wie vor glaube ich es ganz klar dass es
hier wirklich ein besonders abwägenes
Verhalten gibt das Bundeskanzlers und
kein
ängstliches oder zögerndes ziemlich
Franzosen wollen Sie direkt drauf wenn
man die Ereignisse der letzten Tage
Revue passieren lässt also wir haben in
der Woche vor dem 60 Jahre die See
Feierlichkeiten und vor Rammstein die
Diskussion gehabt dass
staatsregierungschefs anderer
europäischer NATO-Länder offen gesagt
haben offen Kritik geübt haben die Polen
haben angekündigt wenn wir die
Genehmigung nicht bekommen ja in
politischen Gründen ja aber
Finnland und so fort baltiken Staaten
also ich sag mal so man hätte eine
wirklich überzeugende Geschichte draus
machen können wenn man sich in Rammstein
als Bundeskanzler hingestellt hätte
gesagt wir sind die wichtigste NATO
Militär
Kraft hier im in Europa mit der besten
Ausstattung
zuvor ist das so wir gehen jetzt voran
oder man hätte spätestens am Sonntag ein
gemeinsames Signal das französische
Staatspräsidenten des deutschen
Bundeskanzlers da waren wir ja insgesamt
250 Abgeordnete aus beiden Parlamenten
zusammen das wäre wäre schöne Dinge
gewesen und das da man das nicht genutzt
hat ist für mich eigentlich schon klar
dass der Bundeskanzler am Montag dann
doch noch
eher gedrängt die Entscheidung getroffen
hat aber ich möchte sie nicht
kritisieren ich finde es richtig dass
sie jetzt getroffen ist und ich setze
alles daran das ist jetzt wirklich
schnell umgesetzt werden ein Stück weit
auf das transatlantische Bündnis
eingehen die Amerikaner fühlen sich
durchaus an der ein oder anderen Stelle
ein Stück weit auch bedrängt selber
Panzer zu liefern viele sagen das ist
militärisch eigentlich überhaupt gar
keinen Sinn macht in der Bremszug zu
liefern die Amerikaner machen es jetzt
doch sogar relativ großen Umfang hat das
Bündnis das atlantische Bündnis
Deutschland USA hat das gelitten würde
ich
nein das denke ich nicht aber es muss
erlaubt sein gerade in einer
Partnerschaft auch ein Konflikt
auszutragen wenn er da ist oder auch
unterschiedliche Positionen und wir
führen die Debatte darum dass wir der
Ukraine helfen müssen ihre Souveränität
ihre
Entscheidungskompetenz zurückzugewinnen
und sich zu erhalten gegen Russland und
ich finde man darf doch nicht außer Acht
lassen dass es auch um unsere
Souveränität geht auch Deutschland hat
das Recht zu entscheiden wann machen wir
was gerade weil wir eine so große Nation
hier sind in der Mitte Europas und das
muss erlaubt sein dass wir unsere
Interessen auch den Amerikanern
gegenüber vertreten und einen Interesse
des Bundeskanzlers ist es dass wir uns
in diesem Bündnis nicht auseinander
dividieren lassen es war eine Stärke
auch die cdu/csu hat das immer betont
das putin ist nicht an einem einzigen
Tag geschafft hat dieses Bündnis
auseinander zu treiben weder in einer
Energiefrage noch in der militärischen
noch wo wir uns auch einig sind in der
humanitären Unterstützung an keinem
einzigen Tag ist dieses Bündnis
gesprengt worden und der Kanzler
arbeitet daran dass diese Koalition
zusammenbleibt vielleicht sogar noch
enger zusammenrückt und da ist es
wichtig dass die Amerikaner an Bord
bleiben das ist ein Interesse auch
Deutschlands und es muss erlaubt sein
dieses eigenen Interesse auch hart zu
formulieren es ist so der Bundeskanzler
das Bündnis eher zusammengeschweißt oder
hat es doch belastet also ich glaube es
wäre besser gewesen wenn wir diese
Signale der Geschlossenheit auch bei der
Frage panzerlieferung früher gesendet
hätten ich sehe ein anderes großes
Problem auf uns zukommen ich erinnere
mich an die richtigen Worte des
Bundeskanzlers der am 27 februar vor dem
Deutschen Bundestag gesagt hat
zwei Prozent für Verteidigung ab sofort
und wenn wir den Haushalt des Jahres 22
angucken und auch die Haushaltsplanung
23 folgende stellen wir fest dass wir
nicht einmal die 1,5% Anteil der
Verteidigungsausgaben am
Bruttoinlandsprodukt erreichen werden
die wir ja in 21 und 20 im übrigen
gemeinsam mit der SPD erreicht hatten
und da sehe ich gerade jetzt im Blick
auf die dickin politisch Debatte in
Amerika ein Riesenproblem weil das war
ja immer ein zentraler Vorwurf der
Republikaner aber auch von Teilen der
Demokraten ihr zu wenig für eure eigene
Verteidigung jetzt sagt der deutsche
Bundeskanzler macht eine solche Ansage
die Außenminister lässt sich nebenbei
gesagt auf NATO-Gipfel auch zu Recht
dafür feiern ich glaube der
Bundeskanzler auch bei seinen Besuchen
im nato-ausland und dann stellt man am
Ende des Jahres 22 fest wenn wir jetzt
den Strich ziehen ich habe die exakte
Zahl noch nicht aber ich glaube sie
keiner bestreitet dass wir unter 1,5
liegen werden und das ist einfach Wasser
auf die Mühlen der Trump Leute ja die
und es macht den beiden das wirklich
schwierig und diese Allianz
verteidigungsallianz weiter zu zu
stärken und zu zu unterstützen wenn er
sich jetzt in den nächsten Monaten im
präsidentschaftsvorwahlkampf sind wir ja
ab dieses Jahr bereits damit
auseinandersetzen muss und da muss ich
wirklich sagen das ist vielleicht der
schwerste
Fehler ja also vielleicht hat man auch
das überschätzt das der Kanzler selbst
sich und Deutschland überschätzt hat am
27 Februar nach dem Motto 2% ab sofort
aber er hat gesagt und es wird nicht
eingehalten und das ist eigentlich für
Deutschland schon eher die Ausnahme dass
der Bundeskanzler was sagt und das kann
dann hinterher nicht gehalten werden
also sie sehen jetzt eigentlich weniger
das
wirklich das belastete Bündnis sondern
sie sehen es vor allen Dingen im Blick
auf die Zukunft dass Deutschland seine
Pflichten nicht erfüllt gegenüber der
NATO Land dich ganz klar ich bin sicher
dass wir das aus Boot geschmiert
bekommen was was wir an konkreten
verteidigungszahlen jetzt vorweisen und
auch wie die Haushaltsentwicklung
vorgesehen ist die Amerikaner gucken
immer auf diese mittelfristige
Finanzplanung das ist kein Gesetz ja ich
habe gesagt dann schreibt doch bitte
schön andere Zahlen da rein ja wir haben
es ja auch immer das Problem gehabt dass
die mittelfristig Finanzplanung niedrige
Zahlen vorsah als dann hinterher
tatsächlich realisiert wurden aber wer
in Amerika weiß das weiß auch im
Kongress niemand dass das Planzahlen
sind die als Orientierung geht gelten
und wir geben definitiv zu wenig für die
Bundeswehr aus auch in 22 und ich
fürchte wahrscheinlich auch in 23 würden
sie auch sagen dass das Bündnis belasten
kann eben in Zukunft gerade nicht
unbedingt jetzt aber dann eben im
Hinblick da das mag sein dass die Zahl
eine Rolle spielt und thematisiert wird
mag sein aber ich also auch im Weißen
Haus im Pentagon sitzen ja Profis die
sehen was alles passiert sie sehen was
innerhalb von 11 Monaten in Deutschland
passiert ist wir liefern Waffen in ein
Kriegsgebiet wir haben die 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen es gibt das
Wort das Kanzlers ob dieses oder
nächstes Jahr umgesetzt wir werden
kontinuierlich die Rüstungsausgaben die
Militärausgaben steigern und im übrigen
glaube ich liegt die Kunst besteht
wahrscheinlich auch im Sinne der
Bundeswehr wird die Kunst darin bestehen
es wird wirklich kontinuierlich über
einen langen Zeitraum zu organisieren
eine einmalige Summe das wissen alle
Politiker geht relativ schnell da kann
man immer Investitionen schnell
beschließen aber über viele Haushalte
möglicherweise über viele Regierungen
und Koalitionen das zu verstehen für die
Bundeswehr das wird die Kunst sein aber
insofern glaube ich können die
Amerikaner da sehr gut einordnen und
noch einmal das ist wahrscheinlich auch
ein Riesenglück das wird Joe Biden am
Weißen Haus im Moment haben und keine
anderen Präsidenten der eine Nähe auch
zu Europa hat der diese Situation
versteht und insofern gehe ich nicht von
einer jetzt belasteten Situationen aus
das so etwas politisch auch genutzt wird
von den einen wie den anderen wie viel
wann Deutschland liefert das mag sein
aber das ist keine nachhaltige
Verstimmung
Herr hart ist um jetzt wieder
um wieder in die Gegenwart zu kommen es
ging jetzt eben um die Panzer auch im
spätpanzer eure bitten und all diese
ganzen Dinge
die Frage ist gibt es irgendwann eine
rote Linie von Material was wir liefern
was überschritten werden kann
ich halte gar nichts von diesen roten
Linien ich halte etwas davon dass wir
uns die Frage vorlegen wie können wir in
der Ukraine zum Sieg verhelfen was sind
die angemessenen Mittel was wir
verantworten können das zu tun und da
ist für mich das Thema Kampfpanzer ganz
klar
bei anderen Fragen bin ich dagegen dass
wir Dinge von vornherein ausschließen ja
also im Gremmel sitzt einer der macht
ein Haken dran was er sozusagen alles
von der Agenda runter bekommen durch
Diskussionen Kampf Flugzeuge ja oder
nein ich würde das auch als extrem
schwierig ansehen deutsche
Kampfflugzeuge den Ukraine in
angemessener Zeit zur Verfügung zu
stellen mit der Einsatzfähigkeit ähm ich
bin nur kleiner chefstechnik offiziell
dort eine Freikarte gewesen ich verstehe
nichts von Fliegerei aber es sind schon
komplexe Systeme nur dass wir von vorne
rein immer wieder sagen also das ist für
uns oder die Presse sagt dann rote Linie
das wird aber dann auch nicht
widersprochen ich würde sagen lass uns
einfach mit den Ukrainern besprechen was
notwendig ist und dann vereinbart werden
vereinbaren wir das im Bündnis und wir
lassen den Mann im Kreml ein bisschen im
darüber wieder unsere gemeinsame
Strategie an den Punkt ist und schließen
jetzt nicht wieder irgendetwas aus wo
wir dann in sechs oder zwölf Monaten
vielleicht doch wieder feststellen wie
bei den Kampfpanzern wie bei den
Schützenpanzern die Linie wird dann doch
nicht gehalten ja es geht ja nicht darum
das deutsche Piloten dort fliegen wir
reden ja über die Bereitstellung von
Material ist auch noch mal was anderes
davon nicht durcheinander bringen und
verwechseln keine roten Linien aufbauen
allein schon aus
strategischen Gründen wir müssen ein
Stück weit für Putin unweg bauen und
kalkulierbar bleiben weil wir sind die
stärksten
was Verteidigungsfähigkeit angeht die
NATO wir sind die stärksten und er muss
damit leben dass man sich uns besser zum
Partner macht so wie das ja unser Plan
mal gewesen ist und wie zum Gegner
kann es sein dass wir irgendwann
tatsächlich darüber sprechen das kann
Flugzeuge geliefert werden ich hoffe
nicht und das ist auch das was vielen
Jahren Sorge macht wenn man sich auch da
anguckt wie die letzten Monate gelaufen
sind wir haben angefangen mit Munition
und gewähren mit technischer
Infrastruktur es ging weiter über
Haubitzen Helme ja gut so als angefangen
und jetzt sind wir über Schritt für
Schritt
Flugabwehrsysteme Marder Gepard beim
Leopard gelandet und das besorgt viele
Menschen ob es wirklich immer weitergeht
in diesem Sinne bis hin zu Flugzeugen
oder sogar Truppen und hat es gab schon
mal einen Punkt wo wir uns einig waren
dass wir den Weg nicht mitgehen wollen
obwohl oft gesagt wird wir müssen alles
liefern was die Ukraine will gab es
einen Punkt wo wir gesagt haben da haben
wir auch ein Interesse und sagen nein
das waren die Flugabwehr werden diese da
wäre es ja schon im Flugzeug gegangen
und wir waren uns in Deutschland und
international einig auch mit den USA das
machen wir nicht das wäre aber der
Schutz durch uns gewesen ja also ist
nochmal eine andere Kategorie es ist
geht in die Richtung aber es ist noch
mal eine andere Kategorie als Beispiel
nennen dass wir natürlich schon auch ein
Punkt hatten wo wir abgewogen haben und
haben gesagt das würde mit Sicherheit
auch der Ukraine helfen aber wir wollen
es nicht weil wir glauben das geht zu
weit und es wäre eine Eskalation die wir
nicht verantworten wollen und das habe
ich eben schon mal versucht auszudrücken
es darf nicht in Frage stehen dass wir
weiter die Ukraine unterstützen sie
müssen sich behaupten können gegen Putin
und es muss erlaubt sein dass wir auch
unseren Interessen formulieren aber Herr
Müller das ist ja genau der Punkt was
machen wir eigentlich wenn z.B März
die Russen so weit kommen dass der Fall
von Kiew unmittelbar bevorsteht also die
Absetzung der Regierung Tötung silenskys
und seiner Regierung die Besetzung von
Kiew und damit eines weiten damit
einhergehend eines weiten Teils des
Landes
ich würde gerne diesen Punkt vermeiden
dass wir an den kommen wir haben es in
den letzten Monaten hinbekommen dadurch
dass die Ukraine eben auch mit
westlichen Waffen mit unserem
Flugabwehrraketen in der Lage war die
Russen soweit auf distanzzeiten deswegen
sage ich möglicherweise hätten wir mit
einer schnelleren Lieferung von
Kampfpanzern z.B im Herbst das
einzuleiten und ich erst jetzt eine
Situation verhindert die jetzt
möglicherweise Tot von der ich nicht
hoffte dass sie eintritt aber wo wir
dann möglicherweise gezwungen werden
noch über ganz andere Dinge zu
diskutieren denn den Fall hier jetzt und
damit den Fall der gesamten Ukraine in
russische Hände
aber ich frage zurück heißt das für Sie
sie würden dann auch Truppen liefern ich
glaube dass wir zumindest was die Frage
der der des Schutzes des Luftraums die
Frage die wir vor einem Jahr diskutiert
haben neu diskutieren werden in dem
Augenblick wo es droht das Ukraine fällt
weil es ja Putin gar nicht um die
Ukraine gibt Amerikaner auch schon
angedeutet aber die Frage die sich dann
stellt das ist natürlich dass wir
überhaupt also es war bisher nicht nötig
in Anführungszeichen also das war es gab
andere geeignete Boden gestützte Systeme
das zu verhindern dass deswegen finde
ich müssen wir zum Beispiel noch
energischer auch diese Systeme liefern
ja genau deswegen bin ich ja auch dafür
zu unterstützen zu helfen auch diese
Waffensysteme zu liefern nur ich glaube
sie haben auch dafür Verständnis dass
das viele Menschen richtig sorge
bereitet wie die Entwicklung der elf
Monate waren und dass sie wirklich Angst
davor haben dass dieser Krieg doch an
uns auch heranrückt dass eine
berechtigte Sorge aber er ist ja also
mit mitverlauf die Verantwortung dafür
trägt der Protein wir haben bis zum
Sommer vorletzten Jahres bis 21 immer
das im Grunde ausgeschlossen das Putin
eine radikale militärische Lösung dieses
Konfliktes sucht wir haben dann erlebt
gruppenansammlungen wir haben auch
deswegen übrigens gesagt wir rusten die
Ukraine nicht auf die Diskussion 5-6
Jahre alt München Sicherheitskonferenz
amerikanische Senatoren lasst uns die
Ukraine aufrüsten um den preisverbot in
die Höhe zu treiben haben wir gesagt ich
auch als Atlantik koordinater Steinmeier
Außenministerin also wir Deutschen
übrigens der amerikanische Präsident
Obama auch die die militärische
eskalationsdominanz liegt bei Russland
und deswegen würden wir wenn wir die
Ukraine aufrüsten sozusagen nur eine
Rüstungsspirale einleiten die am Ende
Protein gewinnt er hat in 21 im Sommer
massiv aufgerüstet massiv Truppen
zusammengezogen ohne dass es irgendeine
Provokation weder der Ukraine noch das
Beste ist noch sonst etwas gegeben ja
wir haben wir haben weiter auf Minz 2
Basis verhandelt die sanktions Regime
waren vergleichsweise moderat waren auch
nicht verändert also nicht verschärft
oder so die Aggression ist ganz klar bei
Putin zu verordnen und das haben wir
bitter lernen müssen trotzdem gern noch
mal nachhaken was Herr Müller gesagt hat
dass die Menschen sorge haben in
Umfragen ist es so dass es quasi halbe
halbe ist dass sie einen sagen auf jeden
Fall müssen wir die Ukraine weiterhin
unterstützen und die anderen dort eher
zögerlich sind und sagen wir haben Sorge
auch Kriegspartei zu werden ab wann sind
wir Kriegspartei wo beginnt das oder
Kriegspartei sind wir in dem Augenblick
wo wir aktiv in Kampfhandlung eingreifen
würden das bürgerrechtlich Truppen also
Boots und Sound oder in
Luft Raum ja der Punkt ist dass wir
völkerrechtlich absolut auf der sicheren
Seite sind weil die Ukraine also bei
einer Stadt uns ausdrücklich um Hilfe
bittet also die Frage ob wir da der
Ukraine helfen dürfen oder nicht die
steht gar nicht außer Frage theoretisch
dürfte man sogar weitergehen
was wir aus anderen wollen aber nicht
wollen also insofern ist die
völkerrechtliche Frage an dem Punkt klar
und 100% der Menschen in Deutschland
haben Sorge ich weiß nicht Herr Müller
wird auch morgens wenn er unter der
Dusche steht als erstes Mal darüber
nachdenken wie werden die nächsten Tage
in der Ukraine also so geht's mir so
geht's vermutlich dem Außenminister der
Außenministerin der Bundeskanzler jeden
Kollegen und den vielen Bürgern es gibt
eine Gruppe von Menschen in Deutschland
die Glauben gibt den Putin was er will
und dann habt ihr Ruhe also dann dann
wird der Ruhe gegeben
ich glaube das nicht ich glaube das ist
ihm gar nicht darum geht irgendetwas zu
bekommen und zu halten sondern dass das
für ihn allenfalls ein Sprungbrett wäre
deswegen wäre den Anfängen deswegen kann
ich den Menschen die das so glauben nur
sagen das ist dann zu großes Risiko wenn
wir uns darauf verlassen und die anderen
sind gespalten in der Frage was ist das
bessere Instrument die die Aggression
einzulegen ja Zurückhaltung zu üben
keine Panzer zu liefern oder aber die
Ukraine in die Lage zu versetzen sich
ähm wehrhaft zu zeigen und den die die
jetzt auch die dritte invasionswelle
zurückzuwerfen ich bin klar der Meinung
die Erfahrung der letzten Monate und die
Einschätzung meiner Einschätzung Potenz
die zweite Option ist besser wie
gefährlich ist es denn Herr Müller das
Putin mitunter damit spielt uns auch als
Kriegspartei zu bezeichnen
wenn wir uns einig sind dass diesem Mann
alles zuzutrauen ist und Herr hart hat
völlig zutreffend beschrieben wie er
eskaliert hat er ist verantwortlich für
diesen Krieg wenn diesem Mann alles
zuzutrauen ist da muss ich das ernst
nehmen dass der auch Schritte
weitergehen würde davon darf man sich
aber nicht einschüchtern lassen sondern
man muss gegenhalten dass ich auch so es
gibt ein Punkt nur wo wir wahrscheinlich
dann eine andere Konsequenz ziehen weil
ich eben auch sage wir müssen aufpassen
dass wir nicht ganz selbstverständlich
an eine Eskalationsspirale reinrutschen
die wir nicht mehr rechtzeitig auch
stoppen können wenn es nötig ist oder
geboten ist und ich sehe das schon auch
bei unserem Bundestag das Wort Marder
war ja noch gar nicht ausgesprochen
geschweige denn dass sie angekommen sind
in der Ukraine und wir haben über den
Gepard gesprochen jetzt passiert genau
das gleiche jetzt ist Entschuldigung
über Leopard gesprochen auch das wird ja
geschweige denn wieder von den
Amerikanern die wahrscheinlich noch
Monate brauchen für ihre panzerlieferung
wird schon obwohl wir noch gar nicht
wissen wie diese Systeme helfen und
Experten ich bin kein Waffenexperte alle
Experten sagen sie werden massiv helfen
werden die Ukraine massiv in eine
Position bringen mit der sie viel besser
umgehen kann und den Russen ernsthafte
Probleme bereiten kann das ist noch gar
nicht passiert und wir reden über
Flugzeuge oder sogar schon über Truppen
und das finde und nein es war ja schon
aus silence geht der ist dann sofort ins
Gespräch gebracht hat aber es wird ja
aufgenommen die Debatte auch wir
sprechen ja darüber so und das das ist
eben das ist etwas was mich sehr
beunruhigt dass wir möglicherweise ganz
selbstverständlich dieses Schraube immer
weiter drehen ohne überhaupt zu
beobachten was passiert jetzt eigentlich
mit den Dingen die wir zugesagt haben
kommen wir in eine Situation die
hoffentlich Putin so unter Druck setzt
dass er eben doch sagt wir müssen
miteinander reden das ist ja eigentlich
unser Ziel ihn so unter Druck setzen
dass er redet also das Ukraine
akzeptiert jetzt lohnt es sich zu reden
auch genau das Ziel
Kampfer kampfpanzerlieferung zu haben
und letzt wirklich in Verhandlungen zu
kommen das bringt uns ja zu der Frage
sind diese Lieferungen letztendlich auch
einen abschreckungssignal an Putin wo er
sagt okay jetzt ist ein Punkt wo ich
tatsächlich ein Verhandlungstisch gehe
rechnen Sie damit
wir haben im Augenblick eine Situation
in der Ukraine das schätze ich so ein
ohne dass ich Militärexperte bin aber
wenn man mit Experten spricht gerade
letzte Woche haben wir das hier wieder
getan andere Fraktionen tun das auch
es gibt im Augenblick die Gefahr dass
das Glück sich doch gegen die Ukraine
wenden könnte weil Putin die letzten
drei Monate besser genutzt hat als wir
will ich jetzt mal sagen weil ich die
Ukraine jetzt nicht dafür verantwortlich
mache dass sie zu wenig Munition hat
dass sie zu wenig Panzer hat die können
das ja nicht selbst erzeugen und das ist
genau der Punkt deshalb wir als
CDU-Fraktion wir haben im übrigen Ende
April diesen gemeinsamen Beschluss des
Deutschen Bundestages gefasst schneller
Waffen der Hitze geparkt sind eindeutig
schwerer Waffen aber Leos eben auch
gewesen und Leo es war halt doch ein
dringender Wunsch ich habe im Sommer mit
dem mit dem ähm ich mir das ist der
Premierminister der Ukraine der ist im
Sommer mindestens zweimal da gewesen hat
wahrscheinlich auch mit ihnen gesprochen
da war eben der Wunsch nach Leopard
Panzern und wenn wir damals diesen Weg
gegangen werden gesagt hätten wir
bereiten uns darauf vor dass wir sie
liefern können für den Fall dass sich
nicht militärisch die Situation
entspannt das hätte also das Angebot die
Karte kaputt denn ja jederzeit sehen
wenn dass sie morgen früh sagt ich höre
auf zu kämpfen ist der Krieg zu Ende
wenn die Ukraine morgen früh sagt wir
hören auf zu kämpfen ist die Ukraine zu
Ende das ist leider die Wahrheit der
dieses dieses Konfliktes dieses Krieges
und insofern hätte man das glaube ich
deutlicher als als Signal verwenden
können und vor allem jetzt brauchen wir
vermutlich vier Monate fünf Monate sechs
Monate bis die Panzer zum Einsatz kommen
und wir wissen nicht was bis dahin alles
geschieht
würden Sie sagen dass Panzer sie haben
ja gesagt man muss eigentlich erstmal
abwarten vielleicht ist tatsächlich
bewirken können dass man an die
Verhandlungstisch kommt oder gehen sie
eher von einer Eskalationsspirale aus
wie sie auch bei die Entscheidung
getroffen und ich finde auch jetzt muss
es schnell gehen so sage ich auch also
da gibt es jetzt wenn wenn eine
Entscheidung fällt da muss man sie auch
umsetzen da gibt's jetzt keine Zeit für
Trödelei und wir haben ja offensichtlich
auch Bestände die wir liefern können
alle anderen in ähnlichen Größenordnung
das ist zusammengerechnet aller Partner
dann doch schon ganz beachtlich was da
in der Ukraine ankommen kann und was
dann auch helfen kann also insofern
diese Entscheidung ist jetzt zu tragen
und umzusetzen aber ich plädiere einfach
immer weiter dafür sich vor jedem
nächsten möglichen nächsten Schritt
immer wieder diese Zeit zu nehmen und
auch das rechten Anspruch zu nehmen zu
sagen welchen Weg man gehen will und
welchen nicht und es ist ja nicht nur es
geht ja nicht nur um Flugzeuge ähnlich
spricht schon wieder von U-Booten und
innenpolitische Themen in manchen
Ländern spielen eine Rolle weshalb sie
schneller sein wollen als andere aber
der der Wert man darf es nicht aus den
Augen verlieren der Wert dieser
Koalition besteht eben darin dass wir
uns nicht auseinandertreiben lassen und
dafür stehen macron beiden Scholz und
das müssen wir uns erhalten gar keine
Frage
in welche Rolle spielt denn in diesem
Zusammenhang auch die Abhängigkeit
Deutschlands vom amerikanischen
beziehungsweise auch vom französischen
Atom die Tatsache dass Deutschland bei
aller Führungsrolle allein gar nicht
verteidigungsfähig ist spätesten Rolle
also Deutschland hat ja seine gesamte
Landesverteidigung seit Mitgliedschaft
der NATO ähm in der Koalition angelegt
es gibt nur einen einzigen Staat und der
liegt nicht in Europa innerhalb der NATO
der theoretisch in der Lage wäre sich
konventionell völlig autark selbst zu
verteidigen das sind die Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika
er selbst die Atommächte Frankreich und
Großbritannien können ihren territoriale
konventionelle Verteidigung nicht ohne
nato-unterstützung organisieren im
übrigen finde ich es gut darüber werden
wir in den nächsten Monaten sicherlich
auch intensiv diskutieren müssen wenn
deutsche Panzer auch außerhalb
Deutschlands auf andere in anderen
NATO-Staaten eingesetzt in der Mama dann
damit so wie wir das ja im Litauen zum
Beispiel tun
weil man damit eben auch einfach guckt
wo ist die effizienteste Möglichkeit ja
also Deutschland wird am besten
geschützt wenn wenn Polen sowie Haft ist
dass sie einem konventionellen Angriff
widerstehen können oder das Baltikum
also insofern stellt sich die Frage
können wir uns selbst verteidigen stellt
sich im NATO Bündnis nicht aber in einem
Bündnis mit der NATO ist eben 1 + 1 mehr
als zwei ja das ist ja diese genau
dieser Punkt dass man ein Niveau an
konventioneller und am Ende auch atomare
abstreckung erreicht über das keiner
hinwegsehen kann über das sich keiner
hinwegsetzen kann
und den Zustand müssen wir erhalten und
da wird von uns Deutschen mehr verlangt
als wir das bisher leisten
das ist seit 2014 so eine Forderung an
uns ich habe selbst die
Koalitionsgespräche damals 2018
mitgeführt wo wir auch dann gesagt haben
wir gucken mal dass wir bis 21 auf 1,5%
bekommen von 1,1 hoch auf 1,5% Anteil
verteilungsausgaben Bruttoinlandsprodukt
das haben wir 21 auch erreicht auf dem
Weg müssen wir vorangehen ich finde es
gut dass wir jetzt die
Regierungsentscheidung haben für die
Nachbeschaffung für Tornado dass wir die
Regierungsentscheidung haben
bewaffnungsfähige Drohnen das war leider
in der letzten Koalition nicht möglich
sei Strom es gab damals eben auch keinen
Angriff Russland gegen die Ukraine die
Welt hat sich geändert die zeitenwände
hat der SPD an diesem Punkt glaube ich
auch also es hat eine grundsätzliche
grundlegende aus umdenken und
grundlegende andere Entscheidungen
zumindest bei der SPD bei den Grünen bei
der FDP glaube ich die waren auch vorher
schon für für überwachungswegetrunken
Herr Müller es wird in diesem Jahr eine
der größten
nato-luftstreitkräfteübungen nach Ende
des Kalten Weltkriegs geben das wird
nicht zuletzt auch über Deutschland
passieren mit 200 Kampfflugzeugen wird
hier eine riesige Übung durchgeführt
würden Sie sagen sowas ist eine große
Provokation auch für Putin oder seid
diese Übung einfach nur den
bündnisschutz auch für Deutschland und
dass das Bündnis funktioniert die Welt
hat sich verändert ich bedauere das dass
wir manche Diskussion der 80er Jahre
leider wieder führen aber sie hat sich
verändert durch die Aggression Russlands
und dadurch ist es auch geboten mit den
eigenen Streitkräften und mit dem
Bündnis anders umzugehen und anders
zusammen zu arbeiten das ist so und die
unsere Bundeswehr braucht stärkere
Unterstützung einerseits auch durch das
die Gesellschaft sie auch trägt mit
ihren Mandaten wir reden natürlich jetzt
heute auch wieder viel über das Thema
Russland Ukraine aber unsere Bundeswehr
ist an anderen Orten auch engagiert im
Irak und Sudan in Mali auch da hat sie
die Unterstützung des Landes verdient
und auch eine entsprechende technische
Ausstattung das muss sein und wir müssen
eben aussehen dass wir innerhalb des
Bündnisses eine andere Rolle spielen
also insofern ja so schwer ist mitunter
auch mir fällt ich war bei den
Friedensdemonstrationen dabei ich habe
mich gefreut dass wir rüstungs- also
rüstungsbegrenzungsbeschlüsse hatten und
dass wir abgerüstet haben aber wir leben
leider in einer anderen Zeit und man
sieht bis Japan eine pazifistische
Verfassung es wird darüber diskutiert
wie wie Japan mit dieser Situation
umgeht eine andere Bedrohung dort im
pazifischen Raum aber leider spielt das
weltweit doch wieder eine Rolle dass man
die eigenen Werte die eigene Demokratie
und den Frieden verteidigen muss
hart würden Sie sagen dass der Westen
irgendwann wenn es um Waffenlieferungen
geht diese vielleicht auch daran knüpfen
muss dass man an den Verhandlungstisch
geht so nackte Motto
gibt es nicht wenn hier jetzt nicht mal
die Verhandlungen tatsächlich
aufgenommen werden wir haben ja hier
einen Krieg zwischen Russland und
Ukraine also einen Angriff Russlands auf
die Ukraine
wo das
Territorium das legitim mit der
rhetorium russland hat es auch in
mehreren Verträgen bestätigt also nicht
nur die Karte von Paris wo ist die
sondern auch zum Beispiel nach Russland
und sowas dass das Abkommen das
Budapester membrandung in dem was
Verhältnis Ukraine Russland geregelt
wurde überall hat Russland die Grenzen
der Ukraine anerkannt und wir haben
gesagt wenn es so ist dass ein ein
potentieller Gegner
freiwillig vertraglich Grenzen anerkennt
dann sind wir wirklich auf einem hohen
Niveau von dauerhaften Frieden angelangt
das war ja unsere Hypothese bis zu
diesem Angriff auf die Ukraine 2014 dass
wir in Europa eine konventionelle
militärische Bedrohung nicht zu fürchten
haben weil es keinen Klammer auf
inklusive Russland kann man zu keinen
gibt der einen einen aggressiven Schritt
vornimmt und die Ukraine muss
entscheiden
wann sie meint Verhandlung sind sind
angemessen denn es geht ja nicht um
einen Grenz Streitigkeit oder so sondern
es geht schlichten einfach darum dass in
der Ukraine jede Menge ukrainische
Zivilisten sterben
Dörfer Industrieanlagen Infrastruktur
zerstört wird Soldaten natürlich fallen
die russischen Zivilisten sind davon
nicht betroffen der Krieg findet statt
auf dem Boden auf dem Staatsgebiet der
Ukraine weil Putin diesen Krieg in die
Ukraine hineingetragen hat und insofern
gibt es meinen dass Erachtens für die
Ukraine eine rote Linie das ist ihr
Staatsgebiet ich sage umgekehrt hat
Russland natürlich trotz allem Anspruch
darauf sein Staatsgebiet unversehrt zu
behalten und es muss dann im Rahmen
einer Friedenslösung eine Vereinbarung
darüber geben wie verhindert wird wie
dauerhaft gesichert wird dass so etwas
nicht mehr passiert Stichwort massive
konventionelle Abrüstung in der Region
und so fort da kommen wir wieder dahin
zurück wo wir 90er Jahren ja schon mal
gewesen sind
und sie sagen Herr Müller dass der
Westen seine Anstrengung bezüglich
Verhandlungen die dann irgendwann
aufgenommen werden sollte noch mal
verstärken muss und darauf drängen muss
und wie sind eigentlich die Kanäle zu
Putin im Moment wird damit einander
gesprochen gibt es in irgendeiner Form
Gesprächskanäle das also erstmal ich
finde ja die Anstrengung ein bisschen
verstärkt werden und das Bittere ist
dass so ein Satz ganz schnell diffamiert
wird von interessierter Seite in dem ein
vorgehalten wird ne du glaubst doch
nicht im Ernst dass man mit Putin reden
kann
das hat selbst ich inzwischen verstanden
dass man mit Putin nicht reden kann ich
finde es richtig dass der Bundeskanzler
oder der französische Staatschef nach
wie vor dort anrufen und unsere Position
vermitteln aber offensichtlich weist man
da auf Granit immer wieder Angebote
machen finde ich aber richtig nur die
Kunst der Außenpolitik und die Kunst des
Außenministeriums oder andere
Außenministerien muss doch darin
bestehen jenseits von Putin Kanäle zu
finden und es sind manchmal ja kleine
Schritte natürlich hoffen wir alle auf
ein Waffenstillstand mindestens oder
vielleicht sogar auf einen Frieden aber
kleine Schritte
Gefangenenaustausch
getreideabkommen das sind Dinge die ja
schon stattgefunden haben das heißt es
gibt eine Möglichkeit ob über die Türkei
über China über Indien vielleicht über
uns oder die Franzosen da bin ich gar
nicht nah genug dran aber es gibt
Möglichkeiten über Gespräche etwas zu
erreichen
und da finde ich muss der Schwerpunkt
unserer deutschen Außenpolitik liegen
jenseits von Putin zu versuchen Kanäle
zu finden wo man für die Ukraine für die
Ukraine etwas erreichen kann unter dem
Zug kommt dass es ja doch
viele erfreulich viele Staaten gibt die
auf der Seite von Deutschland und den
anderen diesen Angriff klar verurteilt
haben aber es gibt eben auch wichtige
Staaten die sich enthalten haben bei der
Abstimmung auf der Seite Russlands
abgestimmt haben nur wenige die kann man
glaube ich vernachlässigen ja in Syrien
und so Nordkorea glaube ich und aber
Eritrea also aber von denen die sich
enthalten haben und da ist die da ist
eine große diplomatische Aufgabe
die auch
nach meinem Eindruck auch als solche
erkannt worden ist im Auswärtigen Amt
und in der Bundesregierung dass man
gucken muss dass wir versuchen die ein
Stück weit davon zu überzeugen dass sie
ihre neutrale Haltung aufgeben und ich
bin selbst Indien berichterstatt an
meiner Fraktion ich bin im Mitte August
in Indien Bestellung aufgeben oder
können diese Staaten vielleicht dann
sogar als Mitte diese starken können
diese Staaten können dann vielleicht
auch mal eine Brücke für Gespräche sein
ob zu Putin oder zu jemand anderem in
Russland das wissen wir nicht aber ich
erlebe zum Beispiel ein Indien das im
Augenblick viel offener ist für
Deutschland und das was wir klassisch
die westliche Welt nennen als das jemals
zuvor in gewesen ist weil Indien ja
immer darauf vertraut hat unser großer
Gegner ist China und Russland hilft uns
und China vom Hals zu halten ja und
jetzt erleben Sie dass der Putin mit der
Krise der Präsidenten von China einen
großen Deal macht das war mit der Ende
Januar da lässt sich da Olympischen
Winterspiele Januar 22 und plötzlich
fällt ihnen wie Schuppen von den Augen
dass sie sich auf ihren Partner Russland
nicht verlassen können das zweite ist
dass der Partner Russland auch nicht
mehr in der Lage ist Indien so zu
unterstützen wie die das erwarten die
haben zum Beispiel sehr viele
Rüstungsgüter die indischen Streitkräfte
aus Russland jetzt haben Sie Probleme
zum Beispiel Raketen zu bekommen für
ihre Fregatten die in Russland gebaut
sind die hier mit russischen Systemen
ausgestattet sind und sofort und ich
finde da müssen wir jetzt einfach
offensiv auf diese Länder zu gehen und
ich habe den Eindruck ich habe selbst
die Ehre gehabt mit dem Außenminister da
Mitte August zu sprechen weil das eben
auch ein Anliegen war da müssen wir
einfach aktiv auf diese Staaten zugehen
und auch Russland und auch ein Stück
weit China demonstrieren dass sie auf
der falschen Seite stehen und dass sie
auf der abschließlichen Wahnsinn was das
ihr Ansehen in der Welt angeht und ich
halte den chinesischen Präsidenten
nebenbei gesagt für clever genug dass er
irgendwann merkt dass dieses Papier der
unverbrüchlichen Freundschaft oder
dieses wie man es nennen kann also ein
sehr sehr weit gehen der
Freundschaftsvertrag
dass dieses Papier aus chinesischer
Sicht ein Fehler war aber er hat selbst
wenn man das chinesische agieren mit
Vorsicht betrachten muss es war ja
wenigstens ein Treffen und ein Gespräch
möglich das Scholz da war mit dem
Staatschef gesprochen hat dass es diese
Erklärung gab zum Thema französischen
Präsidenten mitnehmen sollen das wäre
ein schönes Signal ich bin immer wieder
ein Punkt wo man es noch besser machen
könnte
aber es ist ja trotzdem gut dass der
chinesische Staatschef sich da eindeutig
an dem Punkt Atomkonflikt Verhalten hat
ein kleiner Baustein ändert
möglicherweise nicht die Welt aber ein
kleiner wichtiger Baustein und das muss
genutzt werden das ist die Kunst der
Außenpolitik und würde gerne zum Schluss
der Sendung die Schlussfrage stellen
aber wenn sie
wir haben keine Anzeichen dafür dass
China z.B Russland militärisch
unterstützt und ich glaube das Fest
erwartet hat dass er Mikrochips oder so
etwas aus China bekommt wenn er sie aus
dem Westen nicht mehr bekommt nach
meinem Eindruck machen die Chinesen das
nicht
ich fange bei Ihnen an mit der
Schlussfrage Herr Müller die Frage der
panzerlieferung ist ja durchaus nicht
wenn man Umfragen glauben mag zu 100
Prozent das was alle wollen die
Gesellschaft hier Deutschland ist eher
gespalten wenn es um die Frage geht
Lieferung von Kriegsmaterial wie kann es
gelingen die Gesellschaft an diesen
wichtigen Punkt trotzdem
zusammenzuhalten noch mehr erklären noch
mehr werben auch für den Kurs noch mehr
außenpolitische Debatten führen ich
glaube so eine Entscheidung kann man
nicht einfach von oben herabfällen und
glauben dass alle dann in dem Moment
davon begeistert sind da dafür ist zu
viel in unserem Land passiert in den
letzten Jahrzehnten dafür war es
wahrscheinlich auch in den letzten 30 40
Jahren zu friedlich um uns herum als das
von heute auf morgen alle sagen man muss
diesen Weg geben aber für diese abwägene
besondere Haltung werben und dann damit
mehr Akzeptanz gewinnen die Ukraine
einerseit zu unterstützen aber auch klar
eigene deutsche Interessen
möglicherweise auch Punkte definieren wo
man nicht mehr mitgehen würde oder mit
geht das finde ich es geboten dass es
Aufgabe der Politik sehen sie deine
Gefahr ein größere Spaltung innerhalb
der Gesellschaft also ich glaube so wie
wir heute diskutiert haben ist das ein
Beitrag dazu die Menschen ein bisschen
mehr Einblick zu geben und ich würde mir
wünschen dass der Kanzler vorangeht ja
dass der Kanzler selbst seine Politik
besser erklärt klarer sich bekennen z.B
zu dem Ziel die Ukraine muss gewinnen ja
das würde ich von ihm erwarten weil ich
glaube gerade in so einer Frage
wo viele Menschen unsicher sind und
vielleicht auch viele Menschen ist doch
aus ihrer persönlichen Hintergrund
vielleicht auch sich gar nicht zutrauen
das selbstgebot Teilen ist gerade auch
Führung eines Bundeskanzlers gefragt und
das hat leider aus meiner Sicht in den
letzten Monaten gefehlt und was wir die
letzten Tage erlebt haben mit der
Panzerung
sollte mehr als nur ein ein Aufblühen
sondern es sollte ein auch eine eine
Zeitenwende in in der Art und Weise
wieder Bundeskanzler mit diesem Thema
umgeht aber auch akzeptieren wie viele
Menschen wirklich Sorge und Angst haben
auch das ist Aufgabe von Politiken auch
das Aufnehmen sensibel ich bedanke mich
sehr herzlich für die Diskussion für uns
bedanke mich bei Ihnen ganz herzlich
fürs zuschauen das war unter den Linden
morgen um 22:15 Uhr sehen Sie an dieser
Stelle die für nichts Runde und ich
wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
bei Phoenix
[Musik]